[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's June which marks louder with
Crowder's second annual cultural
appropriation month where we learn and
appreciate all the great cultures this
globe has to offer this week we travel
to the ancient honourable if sadistic
culture of Jabba
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let me with you that is
cultural appropriation month by the way
sake is terrible it is awful everybody
knew I don't want to vilify a entire
nation's beverage of choice that
deserves just to just dive with kamikaze
it sucks but have another sip we are
going to take a wine
yes Aaron's and Hardy berries in a
beverage yeah make it a rocketship
originally in video studios always is
Jared who is not gay sailor Jared today
you can leave him your tweets at NACA
dirt on Twitter or me at s karate with
your comments your thoughts I fulfill my
obligations to our own conclusions
you're good I'm not even convinced about
anything anymore no who knows we'll live
in @g Morgan Jr how are you sir like Ryu
in the short bus yeah he doesn't even
look like Ryu I'm Rui who has brown hair
and then Ken with the blond hair I got
my headphones in all hung up your hey by
the way we have Governor Mike Huckabee
on the show today and then an McElhaney
on the show of course she is a Gosnell
book fam you mainly know her but she not
evil just wrong as it related to climate
change and of course that's in the news
today and affright nation fracked nation
nation is talking a lot about
environmental issues and with the Paris
Accord since we're talking about that oh
by the way a little-known fact we always
to learn about cultures is to appreciate
cultures and that's what also
appropriation ones yeah it is appreciate
culture this is what respect looks like
I don't know if you know this the
Japanese male the average height is four
foot nine Wow four foot nine yes
fully grown and they they tend to have
an IQ that's on average four points
higher than the European counterparts
okay but an inability to love so
learning learning always about the
Japanese people we doesn't take so I
think you got to keep your eye on them I
know I know forgive and forget but
Pearl Harbor that's gonna sting for a
while while we're done with Trump Paris
yes the Paris Accord we talked about
this yesterday Trump held his
press conference today to discuss his
position on the Paris Accord for those
who don't know he decided to pull out
okay but how many of you have frankly
see the Paris Accord okay it's awful is
that all you get for your buddy
okay just it seems like such a waste of
time truthfully and if that's what it's
all about Paris if if that's what you
call moving up that question that's a
man who sticks to his guns that is a man
who sticks his guns respect and I think
that's I give praise for its do good
good on you the president Trump will
talk about that with Governor Huckabee I
know he has some opinions on that huh
and a good good guy good guy the
governor Huckabee fine guy hey in other
news in Lebanon they banned the Wonder
Woman film by the way not gay Jared and
I and Courtney scoffs we'll be reviewing
this film tomorrow we'll get that up on
YouTube or for those who watch morning
riders who get the full review sure
Lebanon banned the film and this has
been trending all over the place
originally was believed that they banned
it because of Godot lady plays one woman
her Israeli nationality which of course
you know is at war I'd convert to hang
out there well I don't think I find a
lot of you convert to Judaism I don't
even know what Messianic Jew yeah yeah I
don't know way to step on the joke early
on there it was originally believed to
be banned because of godot's is really a
nationality in there war where there was
Lebanon but the Lebanese ambassador
later clarified that it was actually a
lack of realism with the film Oh as
Wonder Woman was allowed to drive they
said there's no way he also cited test
screenings leaving audiences really
confused at the lack of her third act
honor killing people were exposing it
yeah she expressed so many opinions
there's no way that's what happened
that's the worse than a disappointing
plot twist no except for when Morgan Jr
just right out there that right out of
the chute but okay now I know what Pearl
Harbor was like so black here's another
these black lives matter was awarded the
Global Peace Prize from
these foundation this is not a joke no
yeah I don't think there's not a hint of
irony and this is the statement they
released the Sydney Peace Foundation
said this is the first time a movement
and not a person has been awarded the
Peace Prize a timely choice climate
change is escalating fast increasing
inequality and racism are feeding
divisive nough sand we are in the middle
of the worst refugee crisis since World
War two yet many establishment leaders
across the world stick their heads in
the sand or turn their backs on justice
fairness and equality
apparently that has something what can
you can you how do you justify this
there's climate change going on just and
there's about justice and 2017 y'all
because they stand head and shoulders
above the rest we salute you black lives
matter
right race knows no bounds when it comes
to the fields thank you black clouds I
felt it and thank you for legitimizing
the Global Peace Prize we'll keep an eye
on that one for years
speaking of which Huffington Post this
one actually got na kijiye
ah he was so upset about this and it's
it really it would've come as we said we
tried to not attribute motive sometimes
people get things wrong Huffington Post
blatantly lie with his article they
blatantly lied let me set it up for you
um they've been using the recent
Portland stabbing to try and push this
this narrative of white supremacists and
try and revive this idea that it's like
American History X out there on every
boardwalk despite the fact by the way
the guy was a Bernie voter but man
incoming so to the extent of their pure
dishonesty Huffington Post wrote a piece
on this because you listen they're
concerned about white supremacy they
actually wrote these words to form these
phrases after a white supremacist killed
six people at a Sikh temple in Wisconsin
in 2012 so they're going back to 2012
that's a hint so you know there's a
there's a hint with the region but you
want me to go reach back to find any
kind of act of terror or killing in the
name of Islam
I don't even you to turn a page it's
right there it's right it's on the cover
of the book right if there's no time I
don't even need a timer my Fitbit my
Fitbit tells me about my pulse less
frequently than Muslims kill people the
name of Islam a 2012 after another white
supremacist slaughtered african-american
churchgoers in South Carolina after
militia extremists occupied a federal
wildlife refuge in Oregon after
radicalized military veterans murdered
police officers in Baton Rouge Louisiana
and Dallas after three members of
crusader militia were arrested for
plotting to attack him oh okay um
something there stick to job did you not
notice the slighted man there they just
throw this all in first if they throw it
in under the premise because this reason
guys a white supremacist that's not
necessarily they're gonna get Bernie guy
the guy seems like he was deeply
mentally disturbed Baton Rouge did they
quote the guy was a more a sovereign
citizen remember by the way he was also
a black guy so pretty hard to be a white
supremacist when they mentioned Dallas
the guy who who carried out the Dallas
cop killings was a member of the new
Black Panther Party amidst the black
lives matter rhetoric give them a peace
process even the source that HuffPo uses
this one point you just that so either
but I'm a white supremacist oh that's a
good point yeah their implication here
is that if you're a veteran you must be
some kind of an extremist or white
supremacist and you look at that you
look at Napolitano not long ago remember
wanted to put tea partiers right-wingers
veterans on potential lists for domestic
terrorism yeah as though they're a
greater risk and they always have to
reach way way back Timothy McVeigh of
course is cited in the article and I
know I know that people are just going
to say well isn't it just hypocritical
for you to say well mental health is a
condition when it's not Islam and then
when it says along you say it's
terrorism no no it's not and let me tell
you why
the reason that Huffington Post had to
fabricate these stories as acts of white
Superman is because there aren't enough
of them is because most of these killers
they had completely incoherent values to
begin with so if you lead a guy who was
a Bernie voter he was a black lives
matter supporter but then he hated
Muslims and he was saying it was our
country if you look at Dylan roof who
was an atheist and then he was a
Confederate but then he might have been
a liberal you look at the Facebook pages
he these people have had come there's no
unifying set of ideas no there's no
unifying set there's no unifying set of
ideals whatsoever as contrasted with the
prescription of killing non-muslims in
Islam as per the founder of the feast
Mohammed there's no conflicting ideas
people aren't confused it's very clear
and that's why they're killing people in
record numbers so is it hypocritical for
me to say ah you know what when someone
says Allahu Akbar I'm killing in the
name of Islam that's Islam and when
someone else says I'm killing because my
toaster said black people are bad he's
mentally ill I don't think it's
hypocritical it's completely fair out
see why this is I see this all the time
on Twitter with these social justice
warriors trying to point out these these
anomalies of things to say I see
Christians do it too right no but it's
so easy it's so easy to bomb state look
okay that's great he's a Christian
screwed up but if you look at his
mission you can easily debunk that with
what we believe what the Bible says
Islam sky like no actually that's well
let's go to reload a let's say I mean
last time Timothy babe
not a Christian no he was not okay sorry
I just had to get that off my chest
what was he though I don't know it for a
little while he was a little bit
Catholic and then he kind of leaned
toward his own deal he um came back at
the very end and said no I'm not I'm not
Christian in the truth I will say that
was a class act for him to come out and
say that he was like you know what I
cleared the air no I don't think it's
fair he didn't have to do that for us
no and he did the most infuriating thing
about this was that when I went to that
page to read this article
ya couldn't stop the video from playing
it just one huffington post
it was huffington post I don't play
reason plays and you can't push pause it
says its processing it's not processing
it's playing BuzzFeed and Vox and Huff
thoughts that autoplay they didn't get a
plate it is terrible hey speaking of
cheap trick Donald Trump tweeted out the
word calf if it v get the National
spindle right now Missy misspelled
coverage on Twitter now to be fair it
does worry me a that he doesn't have his
autocorrect on his keyboard yeah some
people do better without the autocorrect
he needs the autograph it does worry me
that not only did he not think to check
his Twitter tweet before he put it out
on Twitter not on it not only does it
worry me that nobody caught it but that
they still they refuse to fix it for a
long him all of those things worry me I
understand that indicative of a chaotic
administration or some character issues
right yes I know but that's about the
President of the United States it's true
but one follow-up like damn autocorrect
like we've all done what are they fine
but he didn't do that I bet you I bet
you tried that he sent a memo trying to
get people to convince the country that
it's an actual word before I just
concede that guy telev it's a word it
should go from an old slob that's we did
it out he said anybody if who can tell
me what the word means basically the
tweeter says okay I was like oh it's
people know exactly what he meant is
that the problem Jeff he blew pre proves
all the jokes right because member when
- Melania was slapping away his hand and
all the jokes were I'm sure I'll have
some great excuse for this that she was
actually
wisping away the West Nile virus
from his hand instead of just said hey
they had a
tip on the plane yeah she wasn't happy
people are you oka ston that not the
other failures that he's got so hey
that's cool yeah I know I'll give them
that
however the left should take that
sentence in that what these people are
so careless to find if you talked about
that most people probably agree the
problem is that this has been for at
least now an eighteen hour news cycle
non-stop top trends CN n panels on
experts and political strategists and
correspondents coming in to get the
grass likelihood that he would misspell
condo and really if you look at the
possible misspelling see if he possibly
actually missed the V here and there he
actually was trying to write Nazi
they're making a national scandal out of
an error that was likely made late at
night at 12:30 a.m. on the crapper
excuse me mr. president yes I'm just
saying it's emergent matter
I understand but certain urgent matter
because you misspelled the word coverage
on Twitter we'd love to get ahead of the
game tempers not that but I'm going to
change out this jack in the middle the
break for a leather jacket doesn't f she
like sweaty your wife oh my god terrible
it's worse than the Cosby sweater it was
like I was like a hockey bag okay to go
macro here we often do this on a
Thursday I think this is important
because a lot of people been talking
kind of about Venezuela and they why are
you laughing you said right this way
level deok right people are dying in the
streets I'm laughing because the people
who whoa where we're going with this uh
you're laughing yes foreshadowing that's
important a foreshadow high score of
jokes you we've been talking about
Wailer now for a while but people been
talking about certain little snippets
and you don't get the whole picture
right Venezuela is collapsing okay
Venezuela is a disaster like na kijiye
it said it's a joke and it's it's a
shining beacon on a hill of feces that
is socialism it is an exact example of
how socialism always ends up where it
takes a country and the reason I want to
talk about this today is because it's
constant moving of goalposts whether
it's communism socialism big governance
constant moving of well well it'll work
we just they didn't do it right they're
doing it right or we're going to do it
right well here's the thing let me make
let me make a case here I want to hang
people on their words people sometimes
need to be accountable people were
praising Chavez and using Venezuela as
their example for the success of
socialism in the modern world this was
the example they used don't believe me
let's go to Noam Chomsky darling
intellectual love child of the left he
was praising Venezuela for a long time
was actually asking all of his
constituents to look to it and teach it
as an example of successful socialism
you had celebrities who were praising
Chavez and mourning his death Jeremy
Corbyn you had Michael Moore who claimed
that Chavez actually reduced poverty
eliminated 75% of extreme poverty of
Oliver Stone and of course there's
Chavez's favorite pool boy in chief who
can forget the repeated claims and cries
of Sean Penn he is one of the most
important forces we've had and I will
wish him nothing but that great strength
and he has shown over and over again
humans of course I can't be MSE you have
a month ago as obvious I do it in love
you'll know more they do it in gratitude
okay yeah the clip gets worse me that I
didn't believe it I watched you yeah it
gives you don't need you can go and
watch the whole video he praises him he
condemns Americans who act as always a
dictator he says this is one of the most
beautiful elections this is these are
people who are being pulled out of
poverty how dare you criticize Chavez my
dear friend and no one no one in the
world has been more inspirational chap
poses great brother yes both were
fantastic shirts the results well let's
look at the results of mr. inspirational
people are starving there's rioting in
the streets three different university
studies have shown that the average
venezuelan this year has lost 19 pounds
boy night time the towns that it works
every time and here's what's important
because now you'll have all that it's
kind of like the people who say well
actually no I was never on board with
that version of socialism now people
will say well no I own as whele it's
because of Goldman Sachs is suffering to
do so today those day it's because of
capital or in other countries it's
because of interference it doesn't know
I was never on board with it with the
Venezuelan socialism that's not a fair
example okay so they're wrong there put
that one on the board okay but let's go
to the examples that they point to right
now because I want you to hang me on my
words I want you to timestamp this
comeback and fact check all of us now
they're moving on from Venezuela Bernie
Sanders did this in this campaign
they've pivoted so they point to all of
the the Nordic the Scandinavian
countries places like Denmark and
Finland right that's what Bernie Sanders
they said well actually no no that's the
example these are the examples your
Europe you know these are the places
where socialism has worked to a degree
okay let's remember that now they're not
as bad as Venezuela yet but I predict
that they're all going to collapse in
some form of similar fashion let me let
me paint it for you this way socialism
has never ever worked okay and it hasn't
worked for a few reasons we'll get into
the moral reprehensibility of it and how
it just goes completely counter to the
human condition unlike free enterprise
doesn't harness the power of the human
condition
it actually stifles it but outside of
that there are three main reasons number
one is freedom of course socialism
removes systematically freedoms until
you have none left then to socialism
invariable
throughout history has always harmed
countries economically domestically and
then finally it has reduced these
countries to completely insignificant
pissants in the form of global impactors
socialist countries don't provide a
whole lot to the rest of the world so
let's go to the first person first
portion freedom
well let's point to these countries that
people okay there is no freedom in
Europe Germany you don't have freedom of
speech it's it's not a part of their law
certainly in the UK we talked about a
guy who was arrested for singing kung-fu
fighting at a bar any idea what would
happen to us in these countries Germany
has strict no shopping laws what and not
what you can do but what you are not
allowed to do is a business you're not
allowed to open during these hours even
on say you're not allowed to to to shop
in these locations or open your shops
and it's it is unbelievably stifling and
of course with the UK here's something
we're talking about freedom there's no
actual common law right to self-defence
in the UK it's illegal to even purchase
a product which is made to cause injury
but alone fact doesn't stop the people
who are really looking to cause injuries
but it does stop the law-abiding citizen
who says oh I won't buy that frying pan
because I have a good mind to please
write my wife yeah
let's subsidize rapists yeah but ban the
tools to prevent rape the police even
cautioned against using a dye that you
could spray now don't put it in the eyes
because that could then be intended to
cause harm and even though the product
doesn't cause harm you did if you do use
this guy come on these shoes remove the
raid in direction of course but
apologies and you'll find it quite easy
with that dye in your face by the way
would you like to rate me also Mr Bond
here is a condom because vine will just
be walking out just riddled with
venereal disease
so freedom there is no freedom socialism
cannot lend itself to freedom because it
values a collective over the power of
the individual all right
economic outcome well again we see what
happens with Venezuela we see what
happens with all of these other
socialist countries and they move they
move the goalposts all the time they
tried to point to Canada for socialized
healthcare for a long time until they
tried to move it so right now what's
really popular is to point to a lot of
these Scandinavian or these Norwegian
countries Denmark is a great example
they point
well Denmark has suffered a measure
Denmark has had unbelievable growing
pains as far as their economy and if you
want to talk about income inequality
been mark has put taxes that are
absolutely so stifling people can't even
average middle class citizens can't
afford a car due to a hundred and eighty
percent tax jeez a hundred and eighty
percent tax on cars in Denmark and
Bernie Sanders is that human right it's
a human right I know something we're
gonna argue over which bernie is more
accurate Godfrey Godfrey it's gotten to
the point where socialists here because
they had to correct course in Denmark
they realize their socialist economy was
not working people weren't working the
Danish Prime Minister specifically said
because of Bernie Sanders and his ilk
stop calling a socialist we aren't that
anymore we are moving toward a market
economy necessity like you misgendered
him socialist anymore okay
good lord yes we've gotten it wrong for
centuries but we think we're gonna get
right for the next decade like France
will change it up and then we'll go back
European youth their unemployment is
forty to fifty percent
Europe is just they're drowning in the
cost of welfare bills the World Bank
actually this is a quote Europe accounts
for a massive 58% in global welfare
spending while accounting for 7.2
percent of the total population of the
world that is a huge problem and if you
look at their GDP spent on welfare
benefits in certain countries like
Greece or places like Sweden where a
disproportionate number of able-bodied
men do not work if you look at Sweden
which is one of the main economic
drivers in the new industrialized world
as soon as they put in their new form of
Social and you look you look 1970s
onward it's inconsequential they're no
longer on the radar of the global
economy not as they were well and here's
something to this really important
forgets the global positive impact they
talk about income inequality is
eliminated well okay do we believe that
government as a general rule tends to go
above and beyond or do they tend to cut
corners right even if you're a democrat
or republican what do you attend do you
think government there's a reason it's
called bureaucracy some of us have you
been to the poster yes have you been to
the DMV you gotta take a number though I
did yesterday so
good anymore okay take another one and
you're closing in 20 minutes gonna be
bad this is maybe bad someone's gonna
come in you're shooting and everyone's
like they don't understand I said I
didn't see it coming
it's not coming um they say what's the
easiest way if you believe that
government cut that you know they they
cut corners what's the easiest corner to
cut if you're looking to reduce income
inequality is it to create more wealth
is it to make everybody richer or as a
little bit easier just to tax more
people take their stuff give it to
someone else so that people are more
equally poor that's what happens always
in socialist economies people cuz it
will add there's great there's more
income disparity in United States okay
if you have ten percent of a 1 million
dollar pie that's less fair but wouldn't
you rather have that than 50% of a
$1,000 pie if you could have let's say
point zero zero one percent of the total
American economies revenue wouldn't you
take that over two percent of
Venezuela's the point is capitalism free
enterprise have talked about this
creates a bigger pie but because of
people's selfish nature and selfish
bureaucrats looking to cut corners
trying to appease them it's a lot easier
to say look what he has more than you
but yeah but I I have one and he has ten
ten is more than one yeah but his ten is
worth a fraction of what it would be if
you had less and you allowed him to make
more gut socialist governments do not
create more wealth they remove it and as
you see with Venezuela then they blame
the business owners for leaving yeah and
environment invariably you're 50% of the
pie will be worth much less yes fast
forward ten years right it's in
socialist countries
it's like diluting the stock and any
company they run out of toilet paper
like in Venezuela yes they don't have to
and by the way it's not that extreme
obviously in places like like Denmark or
places like Germany or places you know
and we are talking about very small
entirely homogenous populations yeah
they don't use Sweden anymore because if
I grant but invariably it that will
happen the collapse the kind of collapse
you see with Greece the kind of collapse
you're seeing with Venezuela again these
these are places that were always her Oh
Harold it is from the left as you look
at these look at the look at social
limit it can work and then they switch
their tune and
this is what it ends up and then that
comes down to global especially for the
ultimate irony for the left is their
globalists well there is no more global
positive impact when you become a
socialist country for example Swedes
right now they're purchasing more and
more private insurance in Sweden now
because the government is so bad at it
I know I shouldn't need to tell you
about Cuban hospitals but I do because
Michael Moore said they were actually
something to Revere they're obviously
terrible so if you look at here's the
thing if a government of a country is
completely incapable of providing
rudimentary health care to its citizens
okay it's kind of like on a plane put
your put your oxygen mask on first so
you can help somebody else they don't
have any oxygen they have no capability
of getting it they're not gonna help
anybody else on the plane
if you can't provide basic services to
your people or even allow them to a full
create an economy that allows them to
afford these services you have no chance
of helping the rest of the world with
curing diseases creating modern medical
advancements technological advancements
it's because of free enterprise in the
United States that you're able to watch
this either on your television or the
internet or on your smartphone and you
go pop some popcorn in your microwave
turn on a light bulb and maybe flip over
to Seinfeld it's because of the you know
also you don't have polio or rickets
you're welcome and that's because if not
if there's something in there that
wasn't directly from the United States
certainly from a free enterprise
capitalist system capitalism free
enterprise doesn't just help those who
live in the country under its umbrella
it is the only way to positively impact
a global economy now the final step with
this is even if none of this were true
even if you could point to any example
of socialism working of people doing
better of income inequality being
eliminated and everyone being wealthy of
healthcare primitive you that your
country was the sucking other teat of
every other kind as you suck on the teat
of your country let's take a so let's
take this a socialist country that has
its own military that's powerful enough
that they don't have to rely on another
country like say the United States a
socialist country that has such a
booming economy where they have a
surplus and they can tax their citizens
at a rate that it's very socialist
country that is so far along the
economic trail that they are innovating
and willfully giving that and in
distributing it and benefiting
every other country well let's assume
that there's a socialist country that
exists like that guess what it still
doesn't change the fact that it was
built on theft it was built on a crime
even if you take that money and you give
it to a charity but you took that money
by punching someone in the face and
holding him at gunpoint you my friend or
an immoral reprehensible bastard and we
are going to call you on it just like we
are with these celebrities who pointed
to Venezuela well that house of cards
came toppling down how long do you think
it's gonna happen for these other
countries they're pointing to now place
your bets tweet me at s Crowder and him
at not gay Jerrod ignore the stupid
uniform we have Governor Mike Huckabee
coming up next I'm ditching this jacket
[Music]
[Music]
and we're good that's it okay Jerry's at
the bathroom right uh yes
I don't I get more face time on this
show
all the feedback says the fans like me
more than a Cajun why did I want to give
him so much face time when people find
him annoying and they only liked him too
one time I vited them an address what a
life so bright on in here what a
statement it was so cold why don't more
people join more clubs don't I know that
I said support from us it allowed my
mask Steven to fix my leg maybe if they
knew their mug slippers would supports
my health and my leg and all my teachers
that would join more plus it's pretty
affordable 69 for students well I know
I'm just a dog
[Music]
[Music]
all right there we go had to take off
the glass because I realized I was
cleaning the glasses they get they do
get falling you just take them off
especially when you're dive-bombing our
plane to certain to death very glad to
have our next guest on he's been on the
show quite a few times I used to work
with him I was there at Fox News do his
show one of the genuinely nicest guys
I've worked with behind the scenes and I
say that because I have a big mouth and
I've been very open about when people
are horrible behind the scenes this guy
is pretty much what you see is what you
get at gov Mike Huckabee thank you for
being here governor well thank you
Steven and I'm just so delighted that
I'm not having to play the role of the
kamikaze pilot today I've been down that
road a few times it's not much fun
crashing into a carrier so uh yes you're
welcome
well I don't think you take a road to a
carrier I but I don't know it's a flight
trajectory but either way the sentiment
remains it's a glide path it does not
end well and put it that way
yes exactly and okay well speaking of
which the Paris of course I wanted to
have you on it seemed as though this was
just tailor-made for you the Paris
Accord no go pulling out a lot of people
to say oh my gosh oh good you don't have
to do something about climate change
yesterday we went into the ramifications
about how many American jobs would be
lost what it would do to third-world
countries the amount of actual deaths
that would be observable so people can
go back and watch that what is your
sentiment on this is this a huge victory
minor victory Governor Mike Huckabee has
the floor well let me say this Stephen
to quote a great line from the greatest
love story of all time on film
Casablanca will always have Paris
just this whole nonsense about how that
this was going to save the world save
the planet no it really wasn't the US
has taken a number of steps to reduce
carbon emissions and while most of the
pompous anchors on television including
Fox will tell everybody that that there
is no there's an absolute of the signs
here they're rarely and very credible
scientists have said look it may be that
we are seeing an acceleration of global
warming and it could be because of
various human factors and it could be
contributing to it but the
true answer is we don't know the full
extent and it's not quite as cut and
dried now let me take a quick side trip
there's something in the scientific
world that is cut and dried and that's
when life begins life begins at
conception so there's people who say
that there are deniers of science and
they're not willing to accept science
they've yet to accept the science of
biology when it comes to when human life
is created yes I just find the arrogant
snobbery the the the incredible sense of
smugness yeah just this it's very
off-putting let's assume for a moment
that everything that the left says about
global warming and that the science is
absolutely correct the fact is the
United States as I said has been making
significant strides far more so than
China far more so than Russia and the
Middle Eastern countries so we have
contributed far less to yuck and
emissions than other countries and for
us to have entered into this and here's
my simple point if this was such a
fantastic deal why didn't President
Obama take it to the Senate and sell it
because after all isn't he the most
skillful salesman in the history of the
world a man who got a Nobel Peace Prize
before he was barely sworn in as
president because of the anticipation of
what he was going to do yeah so he's
that good then he should have taken this
to the Senate made of the treaty it
would have been very difficult for
Donald Trump to have undone a treaty
yeah didn't do that because he knew that
maybe the science was not yes well it's
it's a bogus deal and well first off
when we talk about science I think the
litmus test is where are you on the idea
of 72 genders and intersectional quantum
physics as it's being taught at the
University of Arizona so I think you
still might be a flat earther yet real
or not to learn believe that there's an
X and a y chromosome and that really
determines are you male or female
I'm also I've got some nerve on you I
think it's fairly clear there are male
and female there's a binary choice now
there may be some people who have
various issues you know I've known
people who have had total surgery
complete reassignment
but this idea that I can just think
myself into something and identify with
it you know I'm gonna think myself into
having paid all my taxes before I pay
any next year and I'm gonna identify as
a full-blown tax payer therefore Sanders
yes you do you sound like Bernie Sanders
you just convinced you oh gosh Bernie
Sanders we had the actuary tables
because the Young Turks want him to run
it's over 25 percent likelihood that he
would die but now now the talk is Joe
Biden is gonna run and he's gonna be a
year older so we could put the birdie to
old rest house the [ __ ] says let it
never be said that the DNC is the party
of old white people well let me just say
that I'm refreshed by this notion the
Democrats are reaching deep out into the
future to get their their bench and you
know the average age of their candidates
between Hillary and Bernie and Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden is gonna be
somewhere north of 75 so I think that it
just shows that if you're a young person
and you're looking for someone to lead
you into the future why wouldn't you
pick somebody you know who is probably
closer in behavior to the people at the
beginning of life drooling and wetting
themselves and it would be for the
people who are at the peak of their
lives yes that's true also if you put
Bernie Sanders in a rock or he just
screams at the wall incessantly so he's
very very similar
it is sad watch he didn't change much I
like can you imagine his mom I don't
know he just keeps screaming that
rattles are a human right I'd so with
this deal think a lot of people don't
understand let's say that let's assume
for a second the science is in okay
let's assume all of this let's assume
global warming humans are the or the
sole cause of it and it's going to be a
catastrophe let's assume that NASA
didn't just come out and say actually
we're gonna have a half a degree cooling
over 50 years but then it's gonna go
back to a degree of warming over a
hundred years let's assume all of this
is there any definitive proof again
we're talking about science right so
science needs to be something that you
observe that you can test either in some
laboratory or recreate the result is
there any definitive proof that this
Accord would do anything to change
climate change no I don't think there is
and that's part of the reason I think
the president made
decision but saying we're gonna pull out
of this Accord he didn't say we're gonna
see if we can trash the environment
we're gonna see if we can pollute the
air in the water and make people die
right you're gonna that from Democrats
you're gonna hear that from the left
you'll hear that from some of the
globalist but that's not what he's
saying he's simply saying we also have
to have people who have jobs who have an
income who have a way to put bread on
their table and clothes on their back
and the Paris Accords we're gonna have
such an impact particularly on poor
people and I find this interesting
Stephen liberals always say they're the
champions of the poor but when you raise
people's electricity rates by 20% and
people can barely pay their electricity
at the bottom of the economic food chain
how is that helping them when you make
it so that people lose jobs and
employers have to cut back on the number
of jobs they offer so that means more
people out of work
greater levels of unemployment more
dependency on government rather than
dependence upon their own industrial
activities of hard work how does that
help poor people come out of the hole
and I'm gonna be very blunt with you I
grew up poor so I know a little about
this I get so tired of people whose last
names are Kennedy and Kerry and
Rockefeller all of whom were on the
Senate Energy Committee who lectured me
one time and I was testifying before
them when I was governor and they were
lecturing me about poverty and finally
after a few minutes of this I just
paused and spawned I said gentlemen I
got to tell you this is a big day for me
because I never ever thought in my life
I'd be sitting in front of three
billionaires listening as a kid who grew
up in a little rent house never
understanding that I would one day be
lectured about the nuances of poverty by
the three of you guys reign is bizarre
well it's like people being prescribed
how to run an economy and how the
government can take control of
manufacturing and distribution by people
like Marx who've never actually worked a
job many people have no idea these
people never contributed to an economy
whatever governor Mike Huckabee says I'm
gonna be blunt for a minute I'm always
waiting for him just one day be like and
but it's just always very polite so the
blunt is really just let me be very
eloquent it's along I'm gonna go after
him and that would just be a real Korean
yes Korean
salon went after governor Mike Huckabee
for me I don't know what the joke was
listen some of your jokes
and you would be the first to say like
some of them don't it wasn't your finest
material I read I was like but I'm the
one you defended a serial pedophile
salon.com three times that I somehow
step in to where you get to take the
moral high ground with Governor Mike
Huckabee so do you read them regularly
and in comments is it on your radar they
don't like you to comment to the people
who don't deserve my time or attention
I'll read a sampling from from time to
time mostly I tell people I do my tweets
for my amusement and their amazement and
not amazed then they're probably not
amused if they're not amused they
shouldn't follow me here's what I find
funny
I'll send something out and immediately
within seconds somebody will say you're
irrelevant nobody's paying attention to
you delete your account I'm thinking
well idiot you're paying attention to me
so much so that within seconds of my
tweet you're jumping all over it
so I must mean something to you and last
time I checked Congress had not passed a
law that required anybody to follow me
on Twitter it's totally voluntary yes
let if you really want to throw them for
a loop
just have like put up a gif of someone
flipping the middle finger like existed
Mike governor Mike Huckabee get hacked
here's the thing they went after Ted
Cruz for a Twitter joke recently - I
really think they hate they hate so much
when conservatives look like regular P
well you know what to the point where we
have actually admitted so we have bits
on the show and we're 911 so we didn't
have on one call on our show it does
pretty well we have we have a really big
demo audience for conservatory ins well
got many many many millions of plays
because someone cut just the sketches
with no accreditation to us and all of a
sudden when people didn't know it came
from it was mega mega viral so the
comedy stands on its own but then one
they just said well you're not funny
because you're conservative it's the
common attack it was with Donald Trump
and Jimmy found the rough they did like
people like conservative feeling like
they are relatable yeah everyday people
just like you know funny making jokes
crack and they think they'd rather has
to be really stiff and rigid and yeah
and I'm relatable
which is funny because you were giving
you I don't know how well you know Seth
Meyers but during that first campaign
you were on SNL and I remember you had
this hilarious bit not get you ID you
were too you were too young but he had a
bit where he was a still running for
president was about super-delegates and
governor Huckabee didn't know that
super-delegates were only for Democrats
really funny the timing was perfect so
at that point because let's be honest at
that point there was no mathematical
possibility for you to win all of a
sudden they were like oh Governor Mike
Huckabee's funny but if you're a threat
he sucks he's not funny have you noticed
that pattern sure I mean that's part of
the deal but I find it liberals for the
most part don't have much of a sense of
humor unless they're making fun of
people that disagree with them right
they have any self-depreciating humor
they simply are devoid of that look I
know that some of my jokes you mentioned
this Stephen so I'll I'll confess up
some of them don't always land some of
them are a lot like the North Korean
missile program you know some may call
the launch pad and some don't know a
second that is a horrible analogy and
that is to shortchange
any of your jokes that do work I don't
think they've ever had one function
governor Huckabee okay well but the fact
is I think conservatives for the most
part are happy people you know we we
kind of know who we are we're cool with
that and and we know that a lot of
people don't agree with us and even hate
us for it but we don't lose sleep over
it and we don't get all worked up and we
don't have to be on medication over it
yeah well some people are but that's
just because again we're happy and we
like to have a good time
governor Huckabee it adds to it in there
right you never you never you never
drink on a bad day that's that's what we
always are governor Huckabee so you said
you know we were talking about this
right before air during the break you
said this administration is kind of 1
for 2 because of we have the Paris
Accord great but you were obviously a
big advocate for the you know United
States Israeli embassy and and that's
not going through explain to people who
may not be aware of what it is we're
talking about and what the president's
policy is regarding that right now
please Stephen a brief history back in
1995 the Senate voted 95 to 2 to
officially move the embassy from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem and recognized
Jerusalem as the legitimate ancestral
capital of the Jewish state he was not
even controversial at the time sure
there was a provision that was stuck in
there and the provision was that the
president every six months could sign a
waiver that would delay the move of the
embassy for that six-month period well
since 1995 is 22 years every six months
a president has signed a waiver Bill
Clinton did it George Bush did it Barack
Obama did it
Donald Trump campaigned on the promise
that he would move the embassy right I
thought he might do it on January 21st
yeah and strongly recommended to him
that he did and I felt that that would
have been a powerful statement to the
world he didn't he was in Jerusalem last
week I was there as well for this
fiftieth anniversary the Jubilee
anniversary of the reunification of
Jerusalem great opportunity to announce
the embassy coming he didn't a lot of
disappointment in Israel over that they
really thought why do you come on the
fiftieth anniversary if you don't
acknowledge Jerusalem as the capital
yeah okay comes back July June 1st is
the deadline that was today and he
signed the waiver so it's it you know
six months it's so hot out there two
questions I was gonna ask sorry before
we are two questions eight why is that
so important to the Jewish people the
people out there who may not understand
I mean if they said well it's is it just
symbolic and then number two why do you
think president Trump signed that waiver
when he promised that he wouldn't well I
think it's important it's not just
important to Jewish people I think it
may be as important if not more so to
evangelicals in the United States people
that were the reason Donald Trump is
president and that's why I don't think
he fully comprehends that support for
Israel among evangelicals ranks right up
there with pro-life as a non-negotiable
yeah and it's a very important issue now
people say why because if we don't
recognize that there is a special place
geographically that the Jewish people
have laid claim to as their ancestral
eternal homeland and Jerusalem the only
people for whom it is ever been a
capital right helps the Jews ever but it
was their capital thirty-eight hundred
years ago and it's the only country in
the world where we don't locate our
embassy in the designated capital of
that country so it's not symbolic it is
substantive and it's a way than wrench
we say that we don't just give lip
service and respect Israel but we
actually respect them and they respect
their capital well I think that's
important for so I think that's
important people to note because we will
have people a lot of folks who watch the
show who are libertarians who say well I
really am against this idea this foreign
putting Israel's interest above our own
and I understand that I don't think we
do that but I also think that you could
be more of a non-interventionist saying
all right let's stop funding everybody
in the Middle East which would mean less
to Israel but if you add up cumulatively
what we give to countries who want to
wipe them off the face of the map it
could be a net positive it's totally a
tenable position for someone to think
that and also understand that by the way
yeah they should be allowed to have
their capital in Jerusalem next why do
you think President Donald Trump didn't
because the left will obviously even
though they couldn't care less about
Israel they'll try to be saying Louis
because of his business interests now
with people who don't like Israel that's
what they will run yeah law goes back to
Russia desaad yeah Saudi Arabia so what
would you think his reasoning is well I
think it's very simple he is surrounded
by a lot of people who have convinced
him that he is the great negotiator and
he can sit down with the Palestinians
and Israelis and make a deal
sign up and and you know maybe maybe he
can but but here's what I don't think so
many people around him who are advising
him understand they tend to think that
this is a diplomatic issue a
geographical issue a political issue an
economic issue an international issue it
is not no it is ultimately a theological
issue yeah and this goes not back to the
1917 Balfour agreement or the 1948
independence of Israel of the 1956 war
with Egypt to the 1967 six-day war the
1973 Yom Kippur War Stephen this goes
back to Isaac and Ishmael and if you
don't take it back there and understand
where the conflict has its roots then
you can sit down at every table in the
world and you're not gonna come up with
some lovely agreement that yeah people
are gonna honor I think that's one blind
spot we've talked about with President
Donald Trump and you could of course
disagree we never want to be
disrespectful to someone who works
directly with him but since he's been an
adult this has kind of been my theory
sometimes where he has his missteps
since he's been old enough to understand
the concept of money well you know
you're you're famous right so when
people meet you in their fans it's a
very different kind of interaction right
away it's an entirely different dynamic
psychologically it changes people since
he's been old enough to run a business
right away he's had enough money and
people have to
we've been in relationships where they
want to get a piece of that or he can
control them in some way or there's a
money relationship and typically when
he's been doing business deals he's been
doing them with people who are in
business they want to make a deal I
don't think he understands yet that
Hamas know it's in their charter to wipe
out Israel they they have no interest in
a deal none that's their that's their
core belief no deal kill Jews it's as
simple as that
and they can promise it by the way you
know in their own code telling a lie is
a perfectly acceptable moral position if
it gets you what you want so even if
they sit down to the table and say oh
absolutely we're gonna behave I mean
look at the Iranians they've never kept
a promise in 38 years since the radicals
have taken over in Iran not once not one
time no nor could anyone believe them
yeah less incredibly gullible like Obama
was who made a deal with the Iranians
thinking that they're gonna well of
course they're gonna keep it yeah give
them hundreds of millions of dollars and
what do they do they immediately laugh
in our face and they go about
accelerating everything they can do to
build a nuclear weapon
I feel like Iran's propositions that
were put on the table when Barack Obama
was president it was it was nothing but
a dare and and and for some reason
whether they were constantly going like
that was the entire good behind it but I
needed free ice cream but it put a steal
and signed it that's what's ironic I
mean this is a country that when they
sign anything they signed it on flash
paper ourselves
they're never gonna keep an agreement
because they don't think they have to
write I know I get that the same thing
they probably gave it to Barack alright
on Twitter very entertaining I highly
recommend you follow him because he's
he's Unchained these days he's not
beholden to anyone he does it for his
own enjoyment that's when you see the
best governor Huckabee at gov Mike
Huckabee governor thanks so much for
making the time I know it's a busy day
for you it's a pleasure to be with you
Steven thank you very much and ready for
this week oh and McIlhenny Irish Irish
[Music]
most of Morgan Reddy's sake just a
little racist pun there most mugs do
suck but I tell you what doesn't the
ladder with Crowder hand edged mug for
those who are members we had the free
week last week ladder with better calm
slash mug club you can send your
complaints to not gay Jarrett I don't
want to hear them it's nine dollars
annually it's 69 dollars even if you're
a white belt you're technically a
student like a G Morgan Jr is there 69
dollars for students veterans active
military listen the amount of people who
joined after getting to watch the show
for a week was incredible thank you so
much when you join not only you get to
the daily show and you could see Jared's
show and there's some bonus content
every week including outtakes but it is
what allows us to continue operating for
free on YouTube you're seeing a lot of
conservatives uploading less content to
YouTube moving to other sites and
sometimes you can't find them the big
irony is that joining the mug Club and
supporting the premium content is what
allows us to fight back on YouTube on
the free platform because Young Turks
we're coming for you we're coming for
you right and don't have there's a dozen
people here a lot with Connor who are
employed if you want to talk about
growing the economy and jobs it's a
small business there are dozen people at
this show of course there you get access
to all the other shows Mark Levin
Michelle Malkin gosh there are a handful
more people and there are more joining
every day especially after this last
this free week trial we had a lot of
people joined so you'll be seeing some
new shows soon you get to support all of
it and my drug habit yeah and you get
all of course you get to support not
gauge a drug habit and what he really
means is Rolaids so you can join it
lottery with credit com / mug Club 99
dollars annually or 69 dollars for
students veterans active military also
announcement we are going to be in
Ireland next week we're going to Ireland
put a goal of hand of the rainbow also
domestic terrorism there's a lot going
on in Ireland we'll be broadcasting from
a pub it's cultural appropriation month
who knows where we will end up next it
could be some third-world country like
Detroit let earth got to become flush
mud club
[Music]
alright let have our next guest it's
cultural appropriation because
appropriating other cultures is to
appreciate their cultures we're learning
about Japan today
little-known fact when it comes to Japan
I'm waiting they have a 94% attempted
suicide rate and the rate of
hermaphrodites is actually 18 times the
global average knowledge is power
yeah knowledge is power the more you
know our next guest we are very glad to
have her on she's been on the show a lot
she's a favorite and she will actually
her culture is next week because I told
you what we're going to be in Ireland
broadcasting from Ireland next week a
local pub down there and we're going to
be appropriating Irish culture and
McIlhenny Gosnell book.com everyone
should go out and check it out it is
doing incredibly well despite the New
York Times trying to act as though it
doesn't exist and McElhinney thank you
for being with us it's very good to be
here thank you so much well we're good I
cannot believe you're going to Ireland
and you didn't invite me oh my god I
want to know about the Pope I want to
know where you're going I'm going to
send people down well honestly I would
never go anywhere else in Europe at this
point very few places but Ireland
doesn't play that game Ireland does not
do the world
well welcome in and in all the migrants
and the rape we're fine with it doesn't
happen in Ireland so I feel pretty safe
well doing don't be filled don't feel
too safe in Ireland by the way just
don't feel too safe and Ireland you
would you'd be surprised at some of the
idea that they have there so just them
yeah well it is comforting it is
comforting the problem is we're gonna
dress up Jared and the most offensive
stereotype possible to see how quickly
he gets his ass kicked
okay so n you ran obviously we've people
we've talked about the Gosnell book
people need to go out read this we were
talking about BuzzFeed and they're just
crazy abortion propaganda but let's go
to a lighter note here
what you you mentioned you just said you
had two fabulous trump derangement
syndrome stories yes unbelievable so the
first one is so as you can see with the
light here I'm gonna be narrow in
Southern California I'm living in the
Hollywood Hills with all the people who
live in the Hollywood Hills yeah and I
thought you know when I moved to
Southern California I'm an Irish girl I
thought you know I should try and soak
up a little bit of this culture of these
strange people who live in southern
California yeah so someone offered a
meditation class in the neighborhood and
I thought you know what I'm gonna go to
the meditation test I go to the
meditation class very nice everyone was
very nice I was the favorite in the
class I wouldn't like to me because I'm
Irish everyone likes you I can't think
of anyone who doesn't like you until
they hear about your ideas behave so
they're all there and I'm thinking if
they only really knew who I was they
really might like me so much but they're
always saying how much they like me and
they did a meditation and one day we did
one meditation was like I want you to
breathe and breathe and breathe in all
the negativity bring it breathe in all
the negativity and then push it off push
love into the push love into it and so
they did that right for five minutes I
was having a ball I was pulling in that
narrativity I was pushing out that love
and then we went around the room how did
you get on how did you get on and I'm
there in my lovely meditative state
feeling very sad and the first person
said well that was really good for me
you know because I was I was breathing
in all the hatefulness all the anger and
the hatefulness from the Trump
supporters and I was pushing love into
it and I'm sitting there going you
should say that and then they came to
the did you push her down and next
person said the same thing and they all
started saying oh my god that's exactly
what I did I was feeling the same thing
I was pushing love into those hateful
Trump supporters and by the way I was
thinking in my head of those hateful
Trump supporters that I love yeah those
people that I love people who are
evangelical Christians and gorgeous
people humble anywhere anyway so that
was my first story my second story next
um if that happens so here I bet you you
can you can bait that situation into
happening again because it's not all too
uncommon when they I know in yoga that
you know breathe this and push this down
so when they say I was pushing down the
trumpeters what I want you to do is walk
right up to them and just start pushing
that person's down wow it's so we
decided you know what I don't want to
fight in every context at him and so I
never pretended who I was that stuff
going to the meditation task my next
story takes from this weekend because
now that I live in the Hollywood Hills I
get invited to pasta dinner parties and
I got a very invited to a very nice posh
dinner party well careful isn't a gay
guy wants your husband to take his keys
so I'm careful I one of the people at
the dinner party was a very em and I
don't identify this guy just a yield
understand why and you a very famous
doctor let's just put it that way a
great man who does wonderful healing and
a great
great person do I know any person you
wouldn't know you wouldn't know him but
people people people in your community
might know him doctors might recognize
he was but don't say ok all his life he
told me we have very nice guy all his
life he has voted Democrat all of his
life until dis election where he voted
for Trump because he couldn't vote for
her because of Israel disguise Jewish
okay so great quick way traveler dinner
party he said you know what really
amazing you know I've sent him yeah but
you know it's amazing the Trump Trump
derangement syndrome he said I've got a
story for you he just spoke recently at
a conference in a foreign country I
won't even identify the country cuz I'm
very conscious of not identifying this
man and he so at the conference he met
an American colleague he's in the midst
of the conversation he told the
colleague that he had voted for Trump so
later on they're in this beautiful hotel
in a very posh place whatever and he
comes down to the bar and she's a huddle
of people including this American man
and they're pointing at him the pointing
at this eminent doctor this healer this
amazing guy who's saving lives every day
right they pointed him and he's pointing
and the man who's pointing as the
American surrounded by French people and
guess what they did they raped him they
spat on the ground they spat on the
ground these are I was close it's
figuring eminent doctors healers and
this is how to react to Trump madness
it's all over the place it's arias we
have a neighbor here in so we're driving
around the neighborhood we're driving
around the neighborhood all of the
poshest houses the most expensive houses
had the Bernie signs on them the next
ones down had the Hillary Clinton signs
my husband wants to put a Trump sign up
but I said no that's who I am Stephen
yes I didn't want the house to be burnt
down and so but anyway we're driving
around driving around and it's very
dangerous driving around here and we
nearly had a car accident
what do we see in a house around the
corner a big trout Stein and I'm
thinking what I might and but film and I
both said we got a call over and see
that guy we have got to go and visit
that guy yeah careful he probably has a
guy next yeah and we go by the Trump
signs gone and then we call by later and
the Trump signs up and he's got it all
secured with like with really secure
wire and it's like really impossible to
remove
so Balaam calls up to the guy's house
knocks on the door
long story anyway but they had a gauge
and whatever and they were scared the
daughter of the house came out and said
is this a trap anyway we've become a big
friend of that guy and he is a trump
supporter and he is up here and you know
we have to huddle together because in a
hostile environment yeah environment
here it is a hostile environment out
there and you're in a land of crazy
people and you still do have to be
careful approaching some of the Trump
said they probably have a gun and
there's there's a more likelihood that
you are blown away I mean listen I
wouldn't blame him if you're on is
Lonnie here someone with a funny accent
saying I said I I support Trump
there's no Trump where you come from I
know your kind I know your kind you
people you're the white people actually
do commit terrorism Irish no no it's
never too soon it's never too Ariens if
ur find a migrant raper gosh yeah the
French the French what we just talking
generalities here about that we have
never gotten more flax than our stance
on climate change and I've been very
reasonable I'm not saying there isn't
climate change I'm not saying that
humans aren't even contributing to it
the question is is it catastrophic is it
imminent and is there anything we can do
about it okay the closest thing that
people are saying they can do about it
well I was there at the summit before it
was a Kyoto Protocol now it's the Paris
Accord there's no proof that it would do
anything yeah at all and the United
States would be disproportionately bent
over and paying for it if I say that and
you say that we make the economic
argument we make the argument listen
this is actually going to hurt a lot of
people put people out of work in the
first world country and kill people who
need energy to survive and they can't
afford it in the third world country on
a scale from one to ten obviously you
you did not evil just wrong people need
to go watch it how bad is this deal it's
crazy bad a good example to really point
out to people so who's really compliant
here who's bending over backwards here
to go with these with these chords with
these kind of measures the Germans and
here's what we need to know about the
Germans they're bad Germans the Germans
are using 40% 40% of their energy is
produced by coal 40%
yeah because of the fact that they've
got rid of their nuclear and because of
the fact that wind and solar are so
unreliable
sorry 40% of their energy has been
produced by coal and their emissions
these awful emissions these awful co2
emissions they were meant to be also
terrified about have gone up by 50% in
Germany yeah the price of electricity in
Germany so the price of electricity in
2012 here in the United States per per
unit was about 12 cent with my 12 cents
here in the United States in Germany I
think the latest numbers yeah 35 cents
yeah 35 cents as you say that is going
to disproportionately affect the poor
but here's the kicker here's the big
kicker where we as American here in
America where we are not complying with
any of this nonsense guess what's
happening to our evil emissions down
down down down down right down down down
down down do you like that movement down
like that down down down and then we'll
take an early appointment boy they cost
by or Hitler symbol for the Jews and
that's caused by fracking because of
fracking the co2 emissions have just
plummeted here United States fracking is
a miracle
it's a fracking miracle there's even
because they're also you're also not
even taking into account how fewer
emissions are not dependent on foreign
foreign resources for energy where they
don't have an EPA they don't care about
it here's what's so crazy and this is
what I love about if I get a 10-man
Colonia on every single day I would but
here's the thing we were talking about
this yesterday we have spend computers
our intern from Germany and he talked
about you actually have to sell their
energy off at a negative price rate
everything that you just said we talked
about yesterday and that's all right no
no no but here's the thing most people
haven't heard of it and they're like
well why haven't I heard of it it's
because they're just not having the
conversations and I hope that's the
value of this show for a lot of people
you and I have these conversations
solitaire and you know what else Steven
the other factor in this is that if
America couldn't kyo continued it not
Paris Accord whatever if they continued
in that in that vein and with all those
agreements right yeah the Americans
would comply because we're low abiding
the Chinese you know I saw a headline
you know the Chinese no matter what the
Chinese lied about SARS
they lied about SARS and let their own
population die and it made it to Toronto
it made it to Toronto yeah and that's
what the Canadians are we had SARS in
Toronto at the Toronto Airport it didn't
make it
States because I didn't fall for but
Canadians there so tolerance of
everything including SARS they tolerated
stars yeah yeah the idea the idea that
people the people that were you know
agree to this Accord the idea that they
should all be treated equally that they
should all be treated the same that
they're all going to comply it's like
like seriously that the Chinese you know
that anyone would trust anything that
the Chinese were saying I've been in
China I've been in facing we can't see
your own hands because of the fact that
there's so much there's so much smog in
the area and the idea that these people
would be lecturing anyone on complying
with anything it's because it's nonsense
these are liars yeah bad Stephen all the
Chinese but most of them is what I
believe he's trying to say gods no yes
yes God's notebook Gosnell book calm go
to Cosmo book calm you know it's really
interesting so the New York Times we
love the New York God the New York Times
Willie Parker dr. Willie Parker okay but
we do have to wrap so go with it
the Christian abortion doctor mark you
Steven Christian abortion doctor if that
isn't an oxymoron I don't know the
definition of an oxymoron but he the New
York New York Times could not love him
more they have done profiles of him our
book was and yes was a best-seller it's
sold out everywhere in 24 hours and
guess who didn't review the book guess
who didn't review the book and guess who
left it off where it should have been on
the New York Times we did eventually get
on the New York Times bestseller list
but know what we should have been lots
of people are reading it and by the way
the one thing I would say as well is I
did an audio version of the book Steven
and a lot of people are buying that for
people maybe traveling in the car irony
was that he hopes to perfectly match
okay we do have to go and McIlhenny and
her husband Phil immaculate they both
work together do great stuff Gosnell
book calm please go read it we have to
go and wrap this show up but a nice
ribbon oh there it is
[Music]
many of you are still unaware of the
items available at louder with Crowder
shop calm not only do they make you look
and feel better but they serve a
multitude of purposes like our social
livin is for [ __ ] shirts assisting in
identifying potential allies I think
it's pretty funny
or our bad hombres firearm t-shirt
helping you know who to avoid I might
have take that shirt to mean you support
some kind of firearm registry or this
one hey look it's my face I hate it
though louder with Crowder shop calm
isn't for everyone but can i buy the mug
from the shop without joining the mug
Club no the rest of you check out the
merchandise at Lauder with Crider shop
comm today
[Music]
I'm going to see thank you so much by
the way too and McElhinney we will be in
Ireland next week so there will be no
show on Wednesday Nashawn Wednesday and
we will be broadcasting live from
Ireland on Thursday be good
Thursday broadcasting live from a local
pub wee baby even be sober
wee there's perhaps and I'm pretty sure
that you can guess which culture will be
appropriate take a wild guess but you
won't get the other three
we're unlucky and that there are fight
there been five weeks in June now last
month in this month five Thursday's
another five Thursday's this week
against five Thursdays you lucky
bastards I know you just get more and
more of the coast keep waiting month and
we've been here here requests frankly
they keep winning we can't stop winning
ah thank you so much the Governor Mike
Huckabee I think next week I think we're
gonna have Laci green on that'll be good
that'll be good interests you know we've
criticized Laci green a lot apparently
she's having dialogues with with people
from the other side of the upstart this
is stupid I can't I wanted to see how
much I could ruin you taking me
seriously though let's be honest at the
point in this program especially if you
had some sock I still don't get the sake
thing I know someone out there is gonna
be furious saying you haven't had the
right sake no it's just terrible
it's an awful beverage we just need to
admit that some cultures have inferior
for example Japan has inferior Hornets
because they're killer Hornets they kill
people
it's terrorize people our Hornets are
better because they only slightly sting
your rice wine is worse than all other
wines not just our wine but France is
wine Italy's wine Michigan's wine even
it is so bad Japan I don't know who
you've tricked by the way this is not
just the this is the official position
of lotta the Crowder yeah they should
know this out there yeah sake is awful
they should be aware about this it's
like because you're taking it's like
flat sweet beer that's what it's it's
like all the elements in London for a
second beer it should be hops barley
yeast you know could could be wheat
right but hops typically malted barley
the Bavarian purity laws don't allow for
a whole lot else but then you have these
American adjunct without awful Bud Light
and that kind of crap the Miller that is
just terrible and it's because there's
corn and there's a lot of rice in it
because it's cheaper so take all the
elements that you don't like about cheap
watery domestic beers
remove the carbonation and that's
knocking are you saying you never get
enjoyment out of just kind of a just
something you know is complete pure crap
beer it's pretty hard it's pretty I
trade or do simpler times I can do sense
but there pilsners not bad no every once
in a while I go on record
do you mind light lime do you were
disgusting you don't like beer na kijiye
doesn't like beer he likes a lot like he
talks to other people he once made fun
of me for drinking gin cocktails when he
cannot have a sip of whiskey
I enjoy fine Jin also whiskey you don't
have to but just don't lie about it
you don't drink beer you don't drink
whiskey ausco also yeah but you have an
Emmy yeah you haven't any wiener anyways
whatever your favorite beers are at s
Crowder at not gay Jared tell us about
your favorite yeah simpler times Pilsner
I will do and if there is absolutely
nothing else for example I'm at a
wedding or something I'll do a standard
budget Budweiser I won't do a Bud Light
anything I'll do a standard buzz
Budweiser it's better than Miller High
Times it's better than Coors Banquet
I'll do a standard if I have to but I
don't like it and it's maybe like one
never good no it's never very good well
I'll build a bat or like a Molson but
Molson Canadian is not sin we have in
Canada we have Molson dry most an export
who knew you had a point that you wanted
to make we usually do kind of wrap up
the week with our our closing thoughts
though tomorrow we have the Wonder Woman
review both me and not gay Jared you had
something that you were talking about
today that you wanted to express so
let's try and make sure you use words
the words in fact this is important
because it's about words and I think the
importance of words we talked a lot
about this this week with uh with
abortion we need to be debunked a
BuzzFeed video and kind of the the
abortion kind of myths going on and that
they didn't the lies I said was BuzzFeed
it wasn't Fox
it was buzzy yeah you're right this is
an awful week by the way
and we talked a lot about well you hear
the statement a lot I hope you never
have to make that decision we've had
guests don't even said you know I hope
you know I never had make is the hardest
issue in my life you people who have had
abortions or gone through divorce you
know it was hard and I've stick a lot
but we really sit in a way it's very
pious like whoa you never have to decide
to get a newborn yeah yeah I hope you
never have to decide it was the hardest
decision of my life
right killing my baby it's like well you
say that in a way that makes me think I
should Revere you for your hard decision
making skills but you made the wrong
this
morally you made the wrong decision
right in it and I was thinking about
that a lot like if people use it I think
we should be really careful about the
when we hear people and the words they
say and and sometimes we can lose it and
tone sometimes yeah and we've minused
like oh wait pause you don't know know
that was a hard decision I would praise
you if you chose the right thing yeah
that would be hard like hey right you
have every reason to abort your baby
everyone telling you you should but you
chose not to if it's a hard position I
commend you where are you going through
you know divorce hey every reason to
leave my spouse every reason to leave it
but it was hardest in my life but I
decided to work through it and press
through it and that's Noble and I was
thinking about that you know it and a
good point is it's more than you don't
even realize you just a decision but on
the plus side when you're actually
making the positive choice uh-huh really
it's defined by a series of actions so
divorce was the hardest decision of my
life
yeah fixing my marriage was an ongoing
process it was the most difficult
process of my life yeah having an
abortion was the most difficult decision
of my life having my baby and taking
care of it or giving it up for adoption
and supporting it and nurturing it the
way that it needed to that's an ongoing
process so often when people say that
it's a pious will they try and they're
trying to set this up right sure it's
almost always in a tone and don't let
this happen I used to have this happen a
lot when I was young and I will tell you
I've definitely matured I've learned
some things and if I could tell myself
hey there are a few mistakes that you
could correct I actually would have
listened I was always someone who was
pretty teachable but I would have people
who would say ah you're a baby you don't
know anything but what's interesting is
even whether I was at fox or when we
started this show when we were at local
radio shows when they would say the same
thing that age always changes with their
age other words you're 24 you're just a
baby talk to them two years later you're
26 you don't know anything because
they're two years older and so these are
people who don't feel solid in their
ideas they don't believe that the
decisions have been have been the right
ones they don't believe that their
actions have been the most productive
ones and so their trump card is you
don't know and it's something you can't
change because I'm older than you and
that's always going to be the case you
don't you don't know what it's like to
have an abortion
well you're right it's kind of like
people saying you can't have it
you haven't had kids so you don't know
and the kids running around with the
curling iron stuffing in its mouth you
know putting the blow dryer in the telly
that's bad I know that's bad I'm not
telling you how to raise your kids but I
would like to see them not die also I
don't want them kicking my back um I see
an airplane it's really annoying kids my
mom dealt with a lot this last week and
she almost she almost gave it out the
guy yeah was like get a hold of your kid
he almost David daddy nuts that's a
really good point it is a good point in
people often say that and they usually
say it's usually said in tandem with oh
by the way I made a bad decision because
you know it it so it's not a saint the
same tone where someone says you know
what keeping my baby when I had every
when I had every reason you know a baby
with Down syndrome or we didn't know
that it would make it keeping my baby
was it was one of the hardest things I
ever did but it's the most rewarding
it's very different from the flip side
someone saying well was the hardest
decision I ever had to make and I hope
you never have to make it this isn't Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire is a really
hard decision
a or see I was pretty confident or of
them yeah I had to choose it's not
there's there's not a moral equivalent
there is a moral clone see between sure
the wrong answer there but when these
really big moral life choices there's
not an equivalency between the two
decisions right when I do think that
generally not always are exceptions but
the person who says you know at the
heart it was the hardest thing I ever
did to to stick out my marriage after
whatever happened or after you know we
weren't communicating husband was
traveling or it was very hard for me to
to decide to have that baby because it
was the right thing to do usually it's
followed by ask me about it they talk
about it yeah on the flip side of the
abortion was the hardest decision I ever
had to make and you don't have a right
to an opinion and shut up and get off me
mate sending divorce divorce is really
hard I don't want to talk about it
usually when someone makes the right
decision they you know you know when you
talk about this was definitely you know
if you've made the right decision people
inherently know sometimes not always
they that's where you need some kind of
outside determining whether it's a day t
or you like to say it's simply laws I
know atheists will so we talked about
the jordan peterson said do you think
people really don't know have a sense of
absolute truth or do you think people
just just BS their way through life
saying i live in my truth I don't think
they were
I think people yeah I ready to think
with most things in life people have a
something inside of us that knows what
real truth definitive truth is or they
know that it exists no it is is really
no one what is but they know that it
exists yes and that's a good point and I
think that's important because if they
know that it exists but they don't know
what it is that's where you see the
manipulation of tone
I'm pious oh you don't know you don't
have the experience you nope no vagina
no opinion another thing we were talking
about this I don't know if we didn't end
up making the show but Huffington Post
wrote about Donald Trump they were
saying he's good if Donald Trump has his
way he's going to allow religious
employers to forego the birth control
mandate in other words what the
interesting that they use the word allow
so someone doesn't really know what the
truth is the truth is that the
government has no right and no authority
and was never intended to have the
authority to force a religious
organization or employer to provide what
they believe in report if against
regardless of your view on abortion but
the language they use it Donald Trump
would allow these organizations to keep
their own money as opposed to paying for
abortions kind of like when they say was
it Elizabeth Warren Donald Trump
president Trump wants to steal from the
pilgrim well interesting you used the
word steal where'd you get the money now
see that meet the reason they're using
the language is because some of the
people have an understanding there's an
inherent truth that truth exists why
because you're single stealing is wrong
but stealing is wrong you use the word
steal okay that's wrong but they also
know that people don't know what that
truth is so they've applied a semi truth
steal yeah that's bad and they're
stealing from the money that we took
stealing from people but the word steal
yeah that's bad so they they prey on
that and they prey on less transparency
and that's something I've always did
we're going to Laci green on next we had
mark Duplass on we're always trying to
invite leftists on I truly do believe
that the solution to most problems out
there if we're actually trying to get to
real truth like na kijiye was talking
about
you've got to eliminate that you don't
know you couldn't possibly know you're
young you're inexperienced and we've
also got to eliminate the half-truths if
we want to get to okay is there real
truth and I think most people do know
that there is
the solution is transparency and open
conversation and guess what that doesn't
mean it's always civil that's the big
irony of this show I mean the intro four
years in the show as I said civility how
about honesty but we have returned
liberal guests who will never go on
other conservative shows because even
though we don't value civility above
honesty guess what
we employ civility on this show we try
to be respectful because our goal is to
get the truth and we believe that it's a
more effective way most of the time
sometimes you have crazy people who come
on the show and just want to yell it on
it when you have to make an example of
them but if we want to get to absolute
truth what the truth is like we're
talking about Jordan Peterson let's just
the solution is pretty simple more
transparency more research more
education informing people more that
means less elitism that means and the
wonderful thing is in 2017 there's no
need for elitism
all information is that everybody's
fingertips whether you're a member of
Mensa or you're riding a short bus with
a room-temperature IQ you can figure out
what the truth is and you're more
equipped to deal with it the more
conversations you've had the more people
you've interacted with so go and do that
this week just make sure you're not
wearing this getup because that tends to
shut down conversation and it's a shame
because it's mostly comfortable
[Music]